in the last 50 years we as a people have
seen the transformative effects of that
membership in terms of the transition
from an agrarian economy to a modern
economic model strong economic growth
free-flowing inward investment vast and
often welcome changes in our social and
civil fabric
and freedom of travel to name but a few
of the beneficial effects we have
witnessed and we are now a small island
on the west coast of Europe at the heart
of a market of half a billion citizens
living peacefully
foreign
there is no strength without Unity
we are stronger together
and while we value peace in the union
you also address us in a time of war in
the Ukraine and of deep economic
uncertainty
both circumstances created by the
unjustified and unprovoked attack on a
member of the European family
the members of these houses have had the
pleasure of hearing from the outstanding
and impressive president zielinski as a
member of the European Union we stand in
solidarity with him and with the
Ukrainian people and as a country we
will remain steadfast in our support for
the Ukrainian people in the time ahead
thank you
I want to acknowledge the presence of
two important people here today
our own commissioner uh Ms marade
McGinnis who needs no introduction I
suppose you're not our commissioner now
but you're you're the commissioner from
Ireland
uh you're very you're very very welcome
and
in the public Gallery uh overlooking her
Shin fan team the designated first
Minister for the Northern Ireland
assembly and we all hope that that
assembly assembles and allows the
important work of government in the
north of Ireland to commence Michelle
O'Neill you are heartily welcome
together with your team
foreign
the floor is yours
thank you so much dear speaker t-shock
honorable members of the doll and chanat
ladies and gentlemen
aguini ushla
today I join you in this home of Irish
democracy
and I do not feel like I have traveled
to the edge of our Union
because well that may be true
geographically
Ireland lies at the heart of Europe in
every other way
this is a country of proud Europeans
and today all other Europeans look up to
Ireland
because you show Europe's best face
innovative
and inclusive
loyal to your history and traditions
open to the Future and the world
this is the country that you have built
indeed in one century of Independence
and half a century of European
membership
it is the country your ancestors fought
for and dreamed of
exactly 50 years ago
t-shock Jack Lynch
made a prophecy about Ireland's future
in the European Union
he was campaigning for Ireland to join
the European economic community
and he explained
that Not only was the future of Ireland
at stake but the future of Europe
because he had the faith
that the Irish people and I quote
could help fashion for themselves and
for future Generations
a better Island and a better Europe
and this is what I would like to talk
about today
most Irish people will agree that EU
membership has made Ireland a better
place
but the other side of the story
is just as important
Ireland has made Europe a better place
Europe owes you
and today I have not come here to praise
our Union and its achievements
but to thank the Irish people
for everything you have brought to our
Union in these 50 years
and everything you will keep bringing in
the many years ahead
and as the Irish language is Synthesia
an official language of the European
Union I have to train my Irish
maguif
[Applause]
let me start with how Ireland has
changed before I talk about how you have
changed Europe
we all know the Irish success story in
our Union
joining the European Union has Unleashed
Ireland's immense potential and has
profoundly transformed this country
in 1973
Ireland's GDP per capita
was around half the European Union's
average
today it is double the average
and this is thanks to your our unique
single Market
and thanks to the Ingenuity of the Irish
people
you have just made the best of all the
opportunities that are there and that
come with the freedom of trade to travel
to study to work all across the European
Union
and Irish Society has blossomed too when
I was a teenager
married Irish women were banned from
working in the public sector for
whatever reason
but because of your accession to the
European community
in 1973 this parliament passed its first
gender equality legislation
and since then the rights of women in
Ireland have come such a long way
already in 1990 Mary Robinson became the
country's first woman president
in her words
The Women of Ireland and I love this one
went from rocking the Cradle to rocking
the system
and indeed now island is one of the best
countries in Europe for female
employment levels
or women in science and technology jobs
and you were also the first country in
the world to legalize same-sex marriage
in a referendum
powerful grassroot movements lead to
powerful legislative changes
you have become a beacon for Europe and
the world
let me again take you back to 1973 for a
moment
the troubles were blazing
and attempts to bridge building between
communities which found her by the
following year
however
farsighted Irish politicians also
understood
that European membership could establish
New Economic and personal ties
and gradually help remove the tensions
which were obstructing the Quest for
Peace
and this is indeed what happened
of course the conflict on the island of
Ireland did not end overnight
and yet
slowly but surely
trust was built
both between Dublin and London
and between communities that lived on
different sides of a wall
Europe was the incentive to look beyond
the barbed wire
to build riches
and reap the economic benefits of
cross-border cooperation
the great European John Hume described
Europe's role as being
both practical and inspirational for the
peace process
and we all know our reunion was once
founded as a peace project
and here
on the island of Ireland
Europe demonstrated this unique power to
bring about peace
Europe's role in the peace process
brought Europe right back to its roots
and this has made brexit even more
painful for all of us
its consequences are most deeply felt on
the island
well beyond the economic dimension
but brexit has also thrust Island and
the rest of the European Union closer
together
Ireland has benefited from the
ireland-clad solidarity of the union and
all its member states big and small
all Europeans
immediately understood
how important it was
to preserve peace on the island of
Ireland
and after brexit our Union has doubled
down on its commitment to peace
for instance we are now providing one
billion euros to the Border counties in
Ireland and to Northern Ireland with our
peace plus program
since it was created in 1995 together
with the Irish and UK governments
the eu's peace program has replaced
border checkpoints with sport venues
schools and community centers
it has brought together people from
different communities
who lived side by side but had never met
each other
one thing is absolutely clear
brexit will not become an obstacle on
the path of reconciliation in Ireland
that is clear
[Applause]
and I'm glad that today our talks with
London are marked by a new more
pragmatic spirit
because the European Union and the
United Kingdom are still members of the
same extended family
even if we no longer live in the same
house
and I can promise you
that whenever the European Union sits
down with our British friends
we will do so
with an honest heart
and an open mind
to quote the great Irish band the saw
doctors
by applying common sense and focusing on
the issues that really matter in
Northern Ireland I believe we can make
progress in resolving the Practical
issues surrounding the protocol
we're listening closely to the business
and Civil Society stakeholders in
Northern Ireland
but the consequences of brexit and the
kind of brexit chosen by the UK cannot
be removed entirely
the solutions we find
must Ensure
that the single Market continues to
function in Ireland and elsewhere in the
European Union
and I think if both sides are sensitive
to this careful balance
a workable solution is Within Reach
I believe we have a duty to find it
and my contacts with prime minister
sunak are encouraging
and I trust we can find the way
and let me reassure you
Island can always count on the European
Union to stand by The Good Friday
agreement there can be no hard border on
the island of Ireland
foreign
[Applause]
members
European membership has done Ireland
good
but that's only half of the story
today I would also like to reflect about
what Ireland brings to our Union
and what it could contribute in the
years to come because Europe is what we
all make of it
and indeed
we can all benefit
from a bit more of the Irish approach to
life
as John F Kennedy pointed out when
speaking here almost 60 years ago
he quoted George Bernard Shaw another
great Irishman
who said
other people see things and say why
I dream of things that never were
and I say why not
an Island's future is built on
opportunity
optimism and openness
and Europe needs this positive vision
for competitive economy for green
digital trade-oriented European Union
with a global role
reinforced by Ireland's strong links
across the Atlantic and with the
English-speaking world
and today I would like to dwell on five
Irish virtues
that will help our Union
to face our common challenges ahead
the first is the Irish passion for
freedom
this country knows what it means to
struggle for the right to exist
and today another European nation is
fighting for its independence
of course island is far away from the
front line in Ukraine but you understand
better than most
why this war matters so much to all of
us
just like our friends in Eastern Europe
you know
that in Ukraine there is more at stake
than the future of one country only
Ukraine is fighting for Freedom itself
for self-rule for the rewards-based
global order
and Ireland has gone above and beyond in
its support to Ukraine
and this these months tens of thousands
of ukrainians fleeing from Putin's bombs
in the east
found the famous Irish welcome here in
the West
you were also an early supporter of
Ukraine's application to join the
European Union
and I want to thank you t-shock
for being such a vocal and determined
supporter
when the citizens of kerson
raised the European unions blue and gold
flag
as well as the blue and yellow flag of
Ukraine
to greet their liberators
it was a powerful visual confirmation
about the people's desire to belong to
our Union
we have shown
that our Union is the home of All
European countries
thriving for freedom and democracy
and our support to Ukraine must continue
for as long as it takes until Ukraine's
ukrainians fully recover what Russia has
tried to take from them
their freedom
this leads me to the second point
Europe should learn the Irish resolve or
some may say the Irish stubbornness
history has never been easy on Ireland
but you have never surrendered your soul
and whenever history hit you
you fought back
a country of immigrants
has turned into a magnet
for Global Talent
after each crisis you have risen up
again
after the troubles
after the financial crisis
and then again after covet
Ireland has constantly transformed its
economy to make it one of the most
successful in Europe
but now
a new crisis is hitting Europe
The Fallout of the war in Ukraine is
Weighing on households and businesses
across the European Union
the whole of Europe needs your
stubbornness today
to keep up supporting Ukraine for as
long as it takes and to break free from
our dependency of Russian fossil fuels
we need your stubbornness
since the start of the war
Russia has cut 80 percent
of our pipeline gas 80 percent but
Europe has managed to replace most of it
we have saved 15 percent of our energy
demand
our storages are full by 95 and we are
safe for this winter
but let's look Beyond
it is no exaggeration to say that we
stand at the crossroads
either we ignore the lesson of this
crisis
and fall again into the Trap
of a carbon lock-in for the future
or we use this crisis to LEAP frock to
clean energy
Renewables are not only good for our
climate
but they are homegrown and that's also
good for our independence and our
security of energy Supply
and here too
Europe has much to learn from this Green
Island
even though you are far away from Russia
and Ukraine you are making
an essential contribution to overcoming
our energy crisis
island is a wind energy superpower
and a key play on our European green
deal
last year
31 of Ireland's electricity came from
wind turbines
a share only topped by Denmark
and you are now doubling down on your
commitments
your Landmark climate Act of 2021 set
the ambitious gold to cut emissions by
51 by 2030. and to increase your
renewable share up to 80 percent
this is good for Island
and this is good for Europe
because you can become a net exporter of
energy
and help the rest of Europe replace
Russian fossil fuel
the new electricity interconnected to
France supported by European funds will
become yet another engine of growth
here in Ireland
and this leads to the third Irish
contribution I would like to discuss
that is ingenuity
this country of poets and artists
has now become a country of startups too
several Irish startups have become
Global players
from stripe the multi-billion Euro
Payment Processing platform
Ed by two Limerick Brothers
to flip dish
digitizing restaurants and bars for
instance by setting up their online
orders and QR codes at the table
access to Europe's single Market
Amplified by Ireland supporting policies
and qualities helps indigenous startups
to grow
and it has also made Ireland hugely
attractive to foreign investment
Ireland has become a hub for the world's
most Innovative companies from farmer to
to high tech
and you are taking the responsibility to
regulate this crucial sector
Europeans depend heavily
on Irish authorities to ensure that the
many Tech Giants based here
comply with our common privacy rules
Ireland can be the home base
for the human-centered internet Europe
wants to build
and the European commission looks
forward to working very closely with
Ireland in implementing the new EU
digital legislation such as the digital
markets Act and the Digital Services Act
this will keep the digital economy fair
and competitive
and this brings me to my fourth point
openness
Ireland is Europe's springboard over the
Atlantic a gateway to the world
two centuries of immigration has given
Island an unparalleled soft power and
diplomatic Network
right now
both the U.S and Australia have Leaders
with proud Irish ancestry
and there are few countries more skilled
than Ireland at leveraging the influence
and friendship of historic diaspora
but it's not just that
Island Ireland is an exporting
Powerhouse
and a staunch support of free trade
and Europe has an unparalleled network
of trade agreements 46 deals with 78
partners
and as we confront a more fragmented
Global Order the value of trade
agreements is increasing
this is why
in the coming years Europe will need to
invest even more in its trade with the
world
it's not just about energy
we must also Supply the essential raw
materials we need for the green and
digital transition
so over the next year we aim to sign
trade deals with New Zealand with Chile
with Mexico
and to advance ongoing negotiations with
Australia Indonesia and India
trade once again is at the heart of
Europe's foreign policy agenda
honorable members
the last
and most important contribution
from Ireland to our European Union is
your optimism
let me go back to 1972 again
when 83 percent of Irish people
voted yes
to joining the European community
and the Irish were by far the most prone
Europe of the three applicant countries
that helped referenda
and today
50 years later
the exact same percentage of people in
Ireland
83 percent
are optimistic about the eu's future
once again the highest percentage of any
country in the European Union
story of Ireland in the European Union
is a story of optimism
and you
the Irish people
have built your own Good Fortune
through thick and thin
Jack Lynch was an optimist when he said
that he could make Ireland and the
European Union a better place
the heroes of the Eastern Rising
and The Architects of the Good Friday
agreement were optimists because they
believed that they could change the
course of history
that is their greatest lesson for us
they dared to look beyond the
imperfection of what is
to see the beauty
of what could be
and this is what Europe needs today
we need to believe that Ukraine can win
this war
we need to believe that we can break
free once and for all from the
enslavement of Russian fossil fuels
we need to believe that a climate
neutral future is Within Reach
and we must do everything in our power
to turn this hope into reality because
it depends on us
Long Live violent long live the European
Union
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]